And the answer here is 5 to the power of n thirds, which is 1.71 to the power of n.
Now if you compare that to the algorithm that we had before,
that was about 1.73, so the improvement here is rather marginal.
But there's two things to be said here--the first one is that
the pre-processing rule that we used was actually a rather trivial one.
It just concerned those vertices that have a single neighbor.
There are much more complex pre-processing rules
that will then allow you to design much better search trees.
And the other thing is that we're using a very simple analysis of the search tree here.
We're basically just saying there are eight possible assignments,
and we're just using five of them; and in a more sophisticated search tree analysis,
what you would do--you would not always have the same number of assignments
in each of the cases that you go into.
So you could have a search tree that, for example, in one possibility,
only assigns two vertices a value;
in another possibility, it assigns five vertices a value; and so on.
And through this refined analysis, you can get much better,
as we'll soon see for our vertex cover.